some seasons back so James Barry wrote a
play about the dream dollar a lonely
man's longing called up from the mists
of nowhere all America was infatuated by
the child who played the daughter it
proved not to be a normal infatuation he
grew into love and it stayed loved both
for the artist and the person the stages
had the biggest share of her but a while
back she came out here long enough to
win an Oscar now she's with us again and
about to present the award for the best
performance by an actor this helm Hey
oh I wish I could tell you how good it
is to be back here but I can't tell you
because I don't think this is the proper
moment to settle down for a chat the
nominees are Louie Calhoun in the
Magnificent Yankee metro-goldwyn-mayer
Jose Ferrer in Cyrano de Bergerac a
Stanley Kramer production United Artists
William Holden in Sunset Boulevard
paramount James Stewart in Harvey
Universal International and Spencer
Tracy in father of the bride
metro-goldwyn-mayer and now may I have
the envelope please
the winner is Jose Ferreira
mr. Pereira is not in the house
but as fred astaire said there is a
group waiting to hear results in New
York at the other end of an open ABC
circuit
I'm sure Jose his wisdom how about it
mr. Ferrer have you anything on your
mind ladies and gentlemen here we are in
New York and now here is our winner mr.
Jose Ferrer hello ladies and gentlemen
3,000 miles away
hello my dear beloved Helen Hayes how
wonderful to hear your voice and I know
it's kind of conventional to thank
people but I'm gonna be conventional
because I'm sincere all of you who are
connected with this picture is Stanley
Mike Carl Frank planner George malla
Bill Prince Morris karnovski all of you
you know as well as I do that it's your
Oscar as much as it is mine also to you
ladies and gentlemen of the Academy who
voted for me you must know that this
means more to me than just the honor
accorded to an actor and from the bottom
of my heart I thank you for what I
consider a vote of countenance in an act
of faith and believe me I will not let
you down and one more thing I think the
most important winner of all tonight is
the man with the long nose himself was
written victoriously through the pages
of dramatic literature for over 50 years
and it is just the beginning for Cyrano
de Bergerac thank you very much
now back to hell ahead I'm taking your
offer and I'm gonna hang out with Cory
on congratulations from us all